face coverings and again
there's a high take-up of working from
home 38
of people worked from home because of
the pandemic in the previous week
and that compares to normal working from
home of about 12
in the previous year and finally on this
slide you can see that people
are really washing their hands
especially when they return from public
places
and it's excellent to see that 89 of
people wash their hands with soap and
water
when they return to their house i'm now
going to hand over to angela for some
further slides
susan thank you if i could have the next
slide please
what we have here is a record of how
much people have been
moving around using google mobility data
for the time period starting from the
first of october
running straight up to the 13th of
november and this is how much people are
moving
relative to what would have been normal
in january
before the pandemic arrived so what's
particularly good to note
is that straight around the 5th of
november
you can see in an orange and a blue line
a big fall in the
number of trips that people are making
for retail and recreation
or through transit stations that's
places like railway stations and bus
stations
not surprisingly given the way things
are this year people are spending more
time at home that's the top
purple line called residential and more
time in parks
although we all know the weather's not
been so fantastic
since the latest set of local
restrictions came in
next slide please
so these are our estimates of how much
the
famous r number has changed week by week
uh since the summer so what this number
counts
is what would happen if one infectious
person
uh were infectious and counts how many
people we would expect
that person to to infect and
this week uh the estimate of the r value
for the
uk is between 1 and 1.2
and the best way to think about that is
that if we had ten infectious people
um on average uh that between them they
would infect
twelve other new people and what you can
see from that graph
is that uh the our number was really
quite high for a while
in late september early october
somewhere between
1.2 and 1.5 and has been falling
but has not yet fallen below one and
it's very important from the point of
view
of the progress of the pandemic in our
country that it should fall below one
because only when r is less than one uh
will the number of
infections in the country be falling
as a final point to emphasize with this
graph
which is that the methods that we use
for estimating
are have to uh by definition really
uh use data that is time lag so these
estimates are done in
using data on how many people are in
hospital
how many people have died sadly and also
using some data about how much people
are moving around
so these are always a backward look so
the fact that r
is still above one for our 13th of
november
[Applause]
and uh we're just going to break away
briefly from that downing street
briefing because there is some more
breaking political news
uh the leader of the opposition's office
uh on behalf of sakir starma have just
announced that the
former leader of the labour party jeremy
corbyn will
not at this time have the whip restored
so he will cease to
continue to be unable to operate as a
labour mp
within parliament this of course follows
the decision by the party yesterday
following a statement from him to
re-select him
as a member of the labour party but he
is being
excluded from the labour parliamentary
party let's get a little bit more
uh from our political correspondent tom
rayner
yes adam following that decision by
labour's
national executive committee panel
yesterday to reinstate
jeremy corbyn's membership there were
questions about whether or not that
meant
he would now be a labour mp once again
allies of mr corbyn have said had
claimed
uh this morning that that would be
automatic however it's clear
uh that kia stammer while he cannot do
anything about the decision of the
national executive committee to
reinstate the membership the party
membership of jeremy corbyn
he does have power to prevent him
sitting within
the parliamentary labour party and in a
statement that he's released he says i'm
the leader of the labour party but i'm
also the leader of the parliamentary
labour party
jeremy corbyn's actions in response to
the ehrc report
undermined and set back our work in
restoring trust and confidence in the
labour party's ability to tackle
anti-semitism
in those circumstances i have taken the
decision
not to restore the whip to jeremy corbyn
i will keep this situation
under review this adam will create a
backlash there was going to be a
backlash one way
or the other because if kia stammer had
accepted that jeremy corbyn
could retain the whip i understand that
there were those in the shadow cabinet
who were considering
their positions there were threats from
other back bench labour mps that they
too
uh would resign the whip in protest
kirstama
chose instead to risk the backlash of
the labour left and there are plenty of
mps
still very loyal to jeremy corbyn who
are likely to be extremely angry by this
tom rainer thank you very much indeed
let's go back to the weekly technical
briefing on the covet outbreak
in number 10 downing street live
speaking
at the moment dame angelina mclean the
deputy chief scientific advisor to the
company
where the amount of infection was
already very high
the the progress of the epidemic had
already flattened off
so that's the north west and the
yorkshire and yorkshire and the humber
in the in the top left there
those also happen to include the parts
of the country that were
under tier three uh restrictions
so that's good news uh that some parts
of the country have already
uh flattened off in uh in this survey
not so good news is that if we look down
at the bottom right
in the south west and the south east uh
progress of the epidemic has continued
to rise
and those are parts of the country well
we're watching the whole country
incredibly carefully next week
and particularly so those parts of the
country that were showing a rise
right up to the 6th of november
i think that's the last slide for me
thank you
um and now i'd like to ask professor
steve perez the national medical
director to present uh relates to the
nhs data
thank you if i could have the next slide
please um
so as angela's shown you uh infection
rates are continuing to rise and as i
have said at previous uh briefings
uh unfortunately uh a small proportion
of people
are sick enough with uh covid19 to
require
a hospital admission and that typically
occurs
up to two weeks after an infection
occurs so there is always a lag in
the hospital admission data compared to
the infection rates in the community
so this first slide shows you the number
of admissions
into hospital in regions of england and
the devolved administrations
and you can see that by and large that
we are seeing
increases in the number of uh people
being admitted uh
into a hospital uh there are some areas
where you can see
uh that there is beginning uh to be
an effect of the measures that are in
place so in england i would point out
the north west which is on the left side
of the chart
in yellow and in areas of the northwest
there were tier three measures in place
before the latest
national english lockdown measures were
put in place
at the beginning of this month and we
are beginning to see
some plateauing of numbers of
patients in hospital and perhaps some
decrease in the north west but you can
see in other areas such as the midlands
uh numbers are still very much rising
on the next slide you can see uh the
picture
uh across all of england in terms of the
number of
uh patients who are in hospital in our
hospital beds
i lasted a down street briefing last
thursday
at that point uh 12 967 patients were in
uh hospital it's now 14 411 so that's an
increase of 1444
uh in the space of just about a week so
we are
unfortunately still seeing increased
numbers of patients
in our hospital beds the
effects of the lockdown measures that
were introduced a couple of weeks ago
will not
feed through into this data i don't
think until
this weekend or next week we clearly
need to see these numbers uh reduce
uh particularly in those areas of the
country with the highest
numbers of patients there is pressure on
our health system
uh unfortunately uh that means uh that
in some cases uh uh that has uh effects
on
other services so it's really important
as we go into this winter that these
numbers come down
uh and we get into the real heart of
winter with much much lower
numbers of covered patients in hospitals
at that point i'd like to pass back to
susan i think for the rest of the slides
thank you steve
so this slide shows us the deaths within
28 days of a positive covert 19 test in
the uk
uh and sadly there were deaths reported
yesterday were 598.
these are the highest deaths we've seen
since may but we should note
that the deaths on tuesday have always
had our highest numbers and that's but
it is still higher than last tuesday
when we had 532 deaths
this these are cumulative deaths that
we've seen
across the uk using 28 days
is 52 745 cases
and the ons have reported accumulative
registered deaths of covet 19 up to the
6th of november
of 63 873 cases
next slide please of course
many people wonder about these people
that sadly may have died because of
another condition
but what we are seeing here is first of
all in the
dark blue the deaths involving covet in
the light gray
the deaths not involving covid and in
the orange line
the all deaths for the five year average
what we can see here which we all
are very much aware of is throughout
march and april
we very much saw an excess mortality
compared to the rolling five-year
average
not just on covet-19 deaths reported to
the office of national statistics
but also in deaths not involving covet
over the summer months
they that equilibrated and became much
more similar to our normal
five-year average that we see but sadly
over most recent weeks we have seen an
excess mortality again
as indicated by the dark blue line and
dark blue
boxes on the most recent weeks this is
clearly concerning and this is clearly
one of the reasons why the national
restrictions had to come into play
thank you very much that finishes the
briefing on slides
yeah so we'll now go to questions i just
want to
invite hugh pim from the bbc
thank you very much indeed can you
confirm
whether subject to a final decision to
be made you are looking at the
possibility of some limited form of
household mixing over christmas
and how that might work so
i think the first thing to say is that
we are very keen that we have
as close to christmas as close to normal
as possible
that requires all of us to make every
effort over this national restriction
period
and even in early december to get the
cases as low as possible
and to reduce the risk of transmission
within households
and between families a final decision of
course will rest with the government
and we look forward to hearing what
those plans are angela do you want to
add anything
like you like everyone i'm also looking
forward to hearing what the plans are
but does that are you modeling the
possibility
of some form of household mixing being
permitted
with other restrictions being in place i
think the best answer i could give to
that is we did send some advice in
over the weekend but we do we genuinely
don't know what decisions have been made
but do you think it's feasible that that
could be allowed
with other restrictions and other
trade-offs well i would reiterate what
susan just said
uh what's really important is that we go
into uh you know
a festive week when when we want to mix
with our friends and our family
uh with the number of infections in the
community as low as possible
so is some sort of christmas possible do
you think so i think it is and i i think
the other thing i would say is that
some of the sage advice previously
suggested that for every
day that we release we'll need two days
of tighter restrictions
so coming into christmas we need to be
very careful about the number of
contacts that we have
to reduce transmission before christmas
and get our cases as low as possible
hopefully the government will make the
decision that will allow us to have some
some mixing but we will wait and see
what that is and then i think
once we have got past the christmas
period if there's been a release
and some socialization we will all have
to be very responsible and reduce those
contacts again
thank you thank you very much i'd like
to go to roland manthorp
sky please hi there thanks as always for
this um
if the r doesn't come below one this
week
is it too late for lockdown to work by
2nd of december
and another question about the google
mobility stats you've said
that people are traveling less since
lockdown but there was a distinct and
pronounced
jump in retail and recreation just
before
lockdown does that partly can
result in the high level of cases that
we see now
and does that cause you a concern for
christmas this
this feeling that once restrictions are
lifted or if they're going to be put in
place
then people will really go out and party
angela can i have that absolutely so
question in two parts your first
question was if r is not below one
uh this week is that terrible news and
the answer is
no that is not terrible news we very
much hope that our will be lower again
but as i've tried to explain
the way we estimate are is very
dominated
uh by what we would call lagging
indicators so people who are in hospital
or people who have died
people who are going into hospital now
are people who got infected weeks ago
so that data stream reflects uh
what was happening before uh the the
latest national restrictions arose
so no i think it's the short answer if
the r that comes out on friday is is not
uh below one or not firmly below one
that does not mean
that the the locked sorry that the
national restrictions have
haven't worked the two are completely
compatible national restrictions work
r is still a bit above one this week uh
that would not cause
me any concern at all in terms of the uh
a bump in activity uh in the days
uh it's really looking at the data here
it looks to me like in the day before uh
fifth of november when national
restrictions came along
um these things are all a worry to us
yes
i i you can you can imagine why people
uh would
would want to maybe get some shopping in
before the shops were all shut
and yes i mean you that this place
exactly what susan and i have both said
that
we are concerned about how can we have a
safe
run-up to christmas so that we can have
some kind
of a a a good family christmas
thank you very much uh emily morgan itv
please
hello uh it's another question about
christmas i'm afraid uh you say that no
decisions have been made
um about christmas and we all know that
we're not going to get
a normal christmas this year i just
wonder what your best case scenario is
for planning christmas what is the
um sort of at best how many households
can we hope to mix with so i don't think
we can answer that this is a government
decision
and it will be a decision that will be
made by government and i know that
they're working hard
to develop an outline of what that will
look like and what the new tiers will
look like
post december the second and what
christmas will look like so we'll have
to leave that to them i'm afraid
do you do you think though that the
government will even countenance
um if cases are still rising or
christmas where we can't mix with
households
i'm afraid we'll have to wait and ask
them i can honestly tell you i have no
idea what their countenance
i really don't know and you have to
remember we're advisors
they decide we advise thank you very
much emily
uh ella pick over good morning
um just touching on to uh
december again and could you um do you
think that socializing should be banned
indoors when lockdown ends in december
um given the evidence from yourself dr
hopkins
and spy m suggests that tier one has no
effect
um and separately um if we could touch
on vaccines please
is it public health england and the
government's intention that every adult
who wants to get a coronavirus vaccine
should get one
and to professor powers please um the
nhs has been instructed
to be prepared to deliver a vaccination
program by the start of december please
could you
update us on how these preparations are
going and are you prepared to take on
multiple different vaccines given
that they have many different
requirements such as temperature and
storage
storage angela do you want to make a
comment
on any of spy modelling
it's pretty straightforward to look at
the
different parts of the country where
different
tiers were imposed and you can see
whether epidemics were growing
shrinking growing faster than it used to
that's that's not a difficult analysis
to do
i'm i am actually pretty confident that
uh
those sorts of considerations will be
taken into account i
i was a bit of a crack record i don't
know what decision will be made
thank you very much um steve uh over to
the vaccine's question please
thank you and and i should say uh
obviously i'm on uh zoom today i can't
join you in dining street and that's
because a member of my household
recently
tested positive for covid and on the
instructions of taste and trace i'm
self-isolating
i should say i'm completely asymptomatic
and perfectly
fine but i will be staying at home until
i have completed my period of isolation
on the vaccination question as i said
last week the nhs has been working
incredibly hard
to ensure that we are ready to deploy
vaccines and to make sure vaccines
can be delivered as soon as the vaccine
trials have finished
and the regulators have looked at the
data and given
approval for the use of vaccines
we will be using our traditional vaccine
routes so
general practices likely community
pharmacy
but we will also be looking at other
vaccine
ways of delivering vaccinations such as
vaccine centers
the vaccines that are at the forefront
of
the production of vaccines so the visa
vaccine you will have heard of in the
press recently
have different characteristics and the
way they can be transported and the way
they can be delivered is different so
we are planning uh for uh different
types of vaccine
and the plans around the delivery
mechanisms
will be contingent upon the particular
vaccine and of course the data that
comes from the trials
and the advice of regulators we will be
saying more about this
in the next few days but meanwhile we're
working hard
we're ensuring that we have the
workforce to do this talked about
general practice who are
stepping up for this but uh johns for
instance are also recruiting volunteers
so we have additional vaccine workforce
uh we will be laying out more of this uh
in the days and weeks to come
and just on the final comment just to
say that the joint committee for
vaccinations and immunizations
advises government on who are the
priorities for vaccination
they have laid those out as interim uh
priorities
but the full priorities will be laid out
once the vaccine's known
thank you very much cats lay the times
please
hi there um looking at
the potential new tears that we might
have
after lockdown and going into christmas
does any of the modeling that you've
provided to government
envisage a new tier 4 that's more
similar to the
lockdown measures that we have at the
moment
and are the mass testing pilots likely
to
play any role will we have any data from
them
in time to potentially make a difference
in terms of what can be eased around
christmas or early in the new year
angela can i hand over the modeling
question to you and i'll take them out
so we
much prefer to talk about modeling work
in consensus statements where we put
together work that's been done by
several different groups
and we haven't gone through that process
yet for the question
you just asked actually i'm missing our
weekly modelling meeting because i'm
here
so i don't know what what they're doing
right right this very minute
um i'm
well so actually the honest truth is i
don't know what has been looked at from
that
from in terms of
more more what's a good word
tougher interventions than tier three
um i think when when i look at the
northwest and the northeast
when i look at what's happened with the
ons surveys there
i see interventions that have worked i
see epidemics that are flattening
and and i feel
there is there is some good news there
and there's
okay um so i think from the point of
view of
mass testing so what we've got is a
large-scale pilot happening in liverpool
at the moment
working very closely with local
authorities directors of public health
academics on the nhs around liverpool
um and we're we're using this as a mass
asymptomatic serial testing work stream
where we're finding people who do not
have symptoms but yet are
at risk of transmitting to other people
and clearly the ambition is that this
will help reduce the prevalence of
infection in liverpool
and therefore that they will come out of
this with less infected people who could
transmit to others
we are in week two they've made great
progress um
more than a hundred thousand people have
had tests um since it started that's
really good news and they've this will
really allow us to understand how to get
people to come forward for testing
who should come forward for testing and
what that intervention
does to the overall prevalence in the
inner city
so thank you finally ian sample in the
guardian
hi thanks very much for this um these
lockdowns
work best when the time is used to beef
up virus control measures so the cases
don't just bounce back afterwards
what meaningful changes have been made
in this lockdown
to keep infections in check after the
second of december and on a related note
the ons data suggests about
650 000 cases in england
what prevalence would you regard as a
good result for this lockdown
come the second of december
andrew do you want to start with that
one so i'll start with the
i'll start with the second one if i may
what would be a well obviously what
would be a good result would be
well let's have a think about during the
during the march lockdown
the number of hospitalizations which was
really all we could keep track of at
that time because we didn't have ons
then
was halving every three weeks i think i
would
well i don't think we're going to
achieve that so
i would say i would be surprised if
let's have a think i don't think we'll
halve over but
i do not think we will half before the
2nd of december there we are how about i
put it that way
because then if i'm wrong we could all
be happy
thank you in terms of of what we are
doing so
clearly nhs test and trace has increased
its testing capacity
uh and that's been a very important
intervention
and that basically has allowed us to try
and work on decreasing turnaround time
for those people who get tests in person
we're also working very hard with local
authorities to
enhance the contact tracing system and
by the end of this month
almost every lower tier local authority
will have local contact tracing in place
so that's really allowed us to step up
and that's an amazing achievement you
know in the summer where we were having
1 000 cases a day
we were contacting on average two to
three thousand people per day
right now with almost 30 000 cases a day
across the uk
we are still working managing to contact
over a hundred thousand people per day
that is a huge achievement in itself and
really what we're building is a local
um international system that will
sustain us for the months to come
and also in the future any future
epidemic and pandemic
thank you very much
well that's it then the technical
briefing weekly technical briefing
particularly for health and science
correspondence
from the experts in number 10 downing
street
i suppose the headlines were that the
public
is being compliant with the restrictions
81 percent of people avoiding
contacts uh 98 percent of people
are wearing masks when they go out
and a big increase on last year and the
number of people
uh working from home a lot of questions
really there
uh about what happens uh when the
current restrictions in england end on
december the second and of course
moving towards christmas i think one
would have to say the answers there
were fairly non-committal but uh
optimistic
that progress is being made although as
the experts made clear
currently the number of deaths and
indeed the number
of hospital admissions is up quite
significantly
in line with the so-called first wave
earlier in the year so
i think one would sum it up cautious
optimism but
uh the fight very much goes on there
from
those briefers just to remind you uh the
epidemiologist from public health
england chairing the meeting susan
hopkins
dr anthony mclean the deputy chief
scientific admiser
and uh stephen powers the national
medical